the very first version of the logistics
robot we built was a balancing robot and
that's called handle and there's that
thing was epic oh it's a beautiful
machine it's an incredible machine so it
was uh
I mean it looks epic it looks like a out
of uh uh I mean out of the sci-fi movie
of some sorts I mean just can you
actually just link around like the
design of that thing because that's
another leap into something you probably
haven't done it's a different kind of
balancing yeah so let me I'd love I love
talking about the history of how a
handle came about because it connects
all of our robots actually
so
um I'm going to start with Atlas when we
when we had Atlas getting fairly far
along
we wanted to understand I was telling
you earlier the challenge of the human
form is that you have this Mass up high
and balancing that inertia that mass up
high is its own unique Challenge and so
we started trying to get atlas to
balance standing on one foot like on a
balance beam using its arms like this
and yeah you can do this I'm sure I can
do this right like if you walk in a
tightrope
how do you do that balance
so that's sort of you know controlling
the inertia controlling the momentum of
the robot
we were starting to figure that out on
Atlas
and so our first concept of handle which
was a robot that was going to be on two
wheels so it had the balance
but it was going to have a big long arm
so it could reach a box at the top of a
truck
and it was gonna it needed yet another
counterbalance
a big tail to help it balance while it
was using its arm
so the reason why this robot sort of
looks epic some people said it looked
like an ostrich or maybe an ostrich
moving around
was the wheels the Le it has legs so it
can extend its legs
so it's wheels on legs we always wanted
to build wheels on legs it had a tail
and had this arm and they're all moving
simultaneously and in coordination to
maintain balance because we had figured
out the mathematics of doing this
momentum control how to maintain that
balance and so part of the reason why we
built this two-legged robot was we had
figured this thing out
we wanted to see it in this kind of
machine and we thought maybe this kind
of machine would be good in a warehouse
and so we built it and it's a beautiful
machine it moves in a graceful way like
nothing else we've built
but it wasn't the right machine for a
logistics application we decided it was
too slow
and couldn't pick boxes fast enough
basically and it was doing beautifully
with Elegance but it just wasn't
efficient enough so we let it go yeah
but I think we'll come back to that
machine eventually the fact that it's
possible the fact he showed that you
could do so many things at the same time
in coordination that's so beautifully
there's something there yeah that was a
demonstration of what is possible